[Music]
[Applause]
for the best achievement in the
production of documentary features the
nominations are artur rubinstein the
love of life bernard chevry producer
before the mountain was moved robert k
sharp producer
in the year of the pig emil de antonio
producer the olympics in mexico produced
by the film section of the organizing
committee for the 19th olympic games the
wolf men irwin roston producer will you
read the winnebago as soon as i get the
thing
as soon as i open this kid
the winner is
arthur rubinstein the love of life
[Music]
francis reichenbach and mrs arthur
rubenstein are accepting for bernard
chevron
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you because i because of this film
i think i met the most wonderful man on
earth
music love and everything he has thank
you man
thank you
well i must say that i'm terribly moved
i'm happy
that we convinced my husband to do that
picture because he really wasn't
he was shy about it he didn't want to do
it
i'm
very moved because
people selected and the academy selected
it and that
everybody voted i mean the friends voted
those who liked it
and then
i'm also very moved by being in this
hall where my husband usually plays and
that he should receive this award i mean
he had to reduce it
it's very moving too
[Applause]
[Music]
and i'm sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i can understand hey you know it's nice
to have you back on the show fred well
thank you thank you bob uh let me ask
you you don't dance anymore do you
no no bob i gave it up last year why
oh you know some things just don't go on
forever
for instance i used to be able to uh
[Applause]
i can't do that anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
i know neither can i you know that's a
shame when you hear when you hear music
doesn't the beat do something to you
nothing
well don't you miss dancing oh sure bob
i sit in my rocking chair and cry all
day long
only all day i only give it about 20
minutes
but you've never danced on the academy
show huh no i haven't and you're not
going to tonight
no no no i'm not that's what you think
elmer
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
thanks a lot bob
for the best achievement in production
of documentary short subjects
i'll take it i'll take it thank you
the nominations are czechoslovakia in
1968 dennis sanders and robert m fresco
producers
an impression of john steinbeck writer
donald rye producer
jenny is a good thing
joan horvath producer
leo biermann arthur h wolf and russell a
mosser producers the magic machines joan
keller stern producer will you announce
the winner fred i'm still winded from
watching you dance i'll cut that out
i'm not winded i was only kidding
you know
thank you
[Applause]
i got it right to be honest i have
the winner is
czechoslovakia 1968
ben sanders and robert fresco
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
i think
we should tell you that this film is
about freedom and
perhaps we should share this with
the motion picture industry of
czechoslovakia
which filmed much of
what is in our film and made it
available to us
i think we're feeling very very
successful tonight and i think we should
i'm sure we share that sense of
well-being with our brilliant editor
marvin wallowitz and our remarkable
composer chuck bernstein thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you